afternoon first let me thank the
organizers for inviting me it's always a
pleasure to visit Berkeley so since this
planning workshop I thought that the
idea was to give not to talk so much
about the last greatest result but
somehow to give a kind of bigger level
perspective on the other hand I don't
think I could eat the whole slot just
being philosophical so I'll try to do a
convex combination of the two that is
try to be philosophical but kind of
anchor the discussion on the basis of
some more concrete work and the concrete
work I'm going to be using the occasion
is some work we've done with a student
who just graduated key mantra copulas
that we call supervised with a suho's
declare so it's real the workshop about
real time let's see how the way
all right so I guess the first question
is what exactly is real time if we take
Steve Boyd's perspective from yesterday
basically if you solve an optimization
problem every millisecond that qualifies
as real time but if that's the case I
guess my talk will not will not fit the
bill travel take a broader perspective
that in my opinion what we mean by real
time is basically that it's closed loop
and closed loop means that the world
that there evolves there is uncertainty
we don't know how it evolves we get
measurements and then on the basis of
the measurements we make decisions and
we act and all that and the time scale
at which this happens could be Steve's
one millisecond kind of image but if
you're thinking about controlling the
Zika virus epidemic obviously the time
scale of where do you deploy what
resources and all that they don't run in
milliseconds they run in in days or
weeks so the time scale I guess can be
can range now stuff happens in real time
on the other hand even in real time
control one needs to keep in mind that
there can be a lot of offline
computation to do well in real time for
example your controller could be
described by some Loney
nonlinear function that takes
measurements and produces controls but
that nonlinear function you can train it
you can design it by doing huge amounts
of offline computations for example it
could even involve training some kind of
deep neural network to learn the right
map and use that one and also the type
of questions that I think are even more
interesting or even at a higher level
which is how to architect the whole
thing that is okay you can spend a lot
of effort to solve a particular
optimization problem but you can also
ask the question who I solve this
problem and not think about the
different configuration of how to set
things up and solve a different problem
all right now so that's one part what's
a real time my title talks about
networks so what I meant by networks was
this kind of subfield that sometimes
people refer to as network science and
let's just do a quick history of this
topic to see where I want to kind of
give a big framework to place what I
will be talking about
so network science I guess starts with
the classical work sixty years ago or so
we get models of random graphs or random
networks either drawn probabilistically
in one shot or later there were models
of preferential attachment where things
come and go and the graphs grow and
these so in this phase we get just
models of graphs then the next stage is
to start having interesting things
happened on those graphs so if each note
there's some kind of state variable and
these state variables evolve through an
interaction and there's a number of
standard models or the clean models
English literature the types of models
that one would put into a textbook so
these are models of epidemic propagation
or Cascades or contagion whichever you
want to call them those models like the
voter model were opinions evolved if you
look at you're at a random neighbor and
you adopt their opinion with some
probability or different models of
opinion dynamics queries you look at
your neighbors of pigeons and you take
the average of those opinions to form
your own and then a bunch of other local
type interaction models like from easing
type models or generalizations of that
you can think of dynamic Bayes nets or
Markov random fields that evolve in time
all of these kind of have the same
flavor in that they're local
interactions that involve probabilities
so you get from here a menu of processes
and that allows for a huge literature to
be will built on each one of these on
these categories the references probably
run in the thousands and lots of stuff
that one can do
all right so huge amount of literature
on
lysing those processes then the next
thing that one thinks about is let's do
something about those processes how can
we affect them and literature started
coming up for example thinking about the
epidemic context natural question is
okay if I don't want my epidemic to
spread what can I do I might go and
vaccinate a fraction of the nodes how
what kind of fraction do I need to
vaccinate so that it will make a
difference
you find the answer then you ask well
can I choose intelligently who to
vaccinate maybe only vaccinate those
nodes that have high degree or those
nodes that are kind of central in the
neighborhood in the Internet in the
network and that gives rise to a fair
amount of literature another type of
intervention of this kind which I would
still call it the static one is consider
some opinion dynamics model where
everybody looks at their neighbors and
gets affected suppose I could pick 10 of
the people in the network and tell them
you don't listen to others but you
always say coke I want to drink coke
okay you're a stubborn agent who's not
going to change your mind and this way
you're going to affect have an effect on
the others who should you bribe to keep
shouting coke and coke and all that so
this literature and papers are coming
out in that direction in the last few
years and where I'm going to get to is
that these interventions are kind of
static that is the network will run the
process will run we do something in the
beginning and we let it run the next
phase where I'm trying to get to is to
go into a closed-loop control where you
actually do something while taking into
account the state of the network and so
here then one starts thinking what are
the kinds of formulations that one
should consider what kinds of hammers
should we be using what are the
bottlenecks how much progress can we
expect to make so I'm going to
illustrate a little bit of that by
talking about a specific piece of work
and then go back to the more
philosophical kind so specific work
involves the epidemic model so called
sis model we have a graph the nodes at
any time can be infected which is red or
non infected or healthy which is white
and the set of in fact it nodes evolves
in time according to the dynamics that
is if a node is infected it becomes
healthy at a constant rate what does
that mean it means that in every Delta
time unit there's probability Rho times
Delta that I'm going to switch to being
healthy on the other hand infections
happen and the rate at which a healthy
node becomes infected is proportional to
the number of infected neighbors so this
node gets infected at rate 2 which means
that in what that in Delta times unit is
roughly 2 Delta probability that this
node will turn and become red so this is
the standard SI es model it's a
continuous time Markov chain and the
state of this Markov chain is the set of
nodes that are that are infected at any
given time all right
the total amount if you think of this
rate Rho that's the rate at which nodes
get cured
think of this is the amount of curing
resources we have a raw resource that's
at each node like her our capacity or
our power to fight the disease at any
node in some sense you are using curing
resources equal to Rho times and now at
any time what's really happening now if
you have so many infected nodes each one
gets cured at the rate of raw in a
probabilistic sense so in a
probabilistic sense there is a drift
that nodes get cured roughly at this
rate but at the same time nodes will
also get infected and the rate at which
infections happen is the cut that
separates red from white nodes each one
of the arcs that crosses this cut is a
path along which an infection can be
transmitted to a healthy node so the
number of infectious pected number of
infections per unit time is proportional
to this cut and these two fight each
other the curing rate drives down the
number of infected nodes the infection
rate derives it up where does this model
come from there's all sorts of
narratives that give inspiration for
models of this kind for anything that
can propagate and that you like or you
don't like you might think that perhaps
it's modeled by a model of this the
literature on this topic has looked
basically into static strategies if we
have a total budget of a curing rate at
which nodes should we put it but that
would happen in the beginning of time
various ways of studying this question
most of the work actually has been on
with approximate kinds of analysis
things like mean field approximation x'
heuristics of various kinds rather
little literature that looks into
dynamic strategies that tries to
allocate curing resource in real time
some of it was again approximate with
min field models and there was one paper
that we knew that would did actually
rigorous analysis but for a very limited
set of graphs where you the answer was
not that hard to see what it would be so
that's where we're taking off from so
let's think again about the static model
instead of having a constant curing rate
at each node we generate that's the same
for each one of the nodes perhaps we can
assign more of that rate at some nodes
and less to others those are that are
more vulnerable perhaps should get
higher during rate and but the total but
let's think of our curing budget the
total is how much during great we have
sitting at each node at any given time
so to make that into a dynamic problem
in closed loop would be one in which we
have a same budget of a total curing
rate but we allocate that curing rate to
nodes in it
I'm dependent fashion and depending on
the current state of the network the
first obvious observation is of course
that in that case you should only
allocate during rates its nodes that are
infected there's no reason to waste your
resources elsewhere so of course in that
sense this is much better than that
because in the static model that you're
curing rate may be sitting on a healthy
note and it's not doing anything useful
so in this context we would like to do
something if an epidemic has started to
extinguish that epidemic and to have
that happen quickly and you can rephrase
that question we can turn it around and
ask what kind of budget do I need in
order to kill the epidemic quickly okay
you could think of trying to solve that
problem in an exact way the exact
methodology for doing such with such
problems is of course dynamic
programming or Markov decision theory
you can write down the objective of
minimizing the expected time to
extinction dynamic programming in
principle gives you an optimal policy
but to run dynamic programming you need
one variable for each state a state in
this context is a configuration that is
a subset of nodes who is in fact and who
is not that's an exponential state space
that by itself doesn't prove that the
problem is intractable but I think
there's at least one person in this room
who could prove that the problem is at
least np-hard have to think about it for
ten minutes or so all right
so you cannot that will not really take
you anywhere if you try to go for an
exact solution one could think about
approximate dynamic programming methods
which are pretty powerful and can give
you good solutions if you are willing to
spend the time to get them to work right
so in approximate dynamic programming
basically the value function of dynamic
programming gets approximated by some
parametric form and quite often it gives
it gives good solutions we might get
solutions that are good enough let's say
to be
unquote practical if we're supposed to
be solving a practical problem here and
now work of this kind has been going on
for some time has had its ups and downs
hasn't been heard that much lately but
now with deep neural networks and deep
reinforcement learning out there in the
news one is kind of tempted okay let's
throw that hammer in there
yeah it's not no it's not necessarily
proportional to the degree I don't think
there's any urine that gives a simple
characterization at the best David might
know the answer better but at the best
it would be some way an efficient
algorithm for optimizing to revise or
getting them close to optimal but but
there's no clean answer to that all
right
so we could throw deep neural networks
and get if you give me an instance of
this problem give me a graph generate a
solution that would be an interesting
exercise I'm not sure if it's an
exercise that's worth doing because you
solve the optimal problem for a specific
graph you have it there okay what do you
do the next day that you're dealing with
another graph you retrain your deep
neural network and and in the end do you
even get a decent publication out of
that stuff I mean it's one thing to
solve the problem of the to get a deep
neural network to play gohu well because
that will get you in the New York Times
but I don't think that good policy for
that problem will attract that kind of
publicity so when we want to start with
those problems sometimes cities that we
actually want to compute solutions but
sometimes maybe we want to get insights
that will help us so let's take the
other road instead of DP here and think
about what insights we can get so what's
the structure of the problem
secure from to the following we know
that any epidemic is going to be extinct
eventually just because of randomness it
may happen that all the infected not
suddenly become healthy and the dies off
but this is a rare event the expected
time until it happens in general would
be exponential in the number of nodes
but if we have enough curing resources
if we can guarantee that at any time the
total curing rate that we applied to
infected node is bigger than the cut
which is the rate at which infections
happen then we're going to have a
downward drift in the number of infected
nodes and the time of to extinction will
be small so we know that with enough
curing resources we can get fast enough
extinction how many curing resources do
we need let's get some insight well if
we have a line graph to get quick
extinction you could give a curing rate
of two at each one it's all the nodes
nodes infections along that arc happen
at the rate 1 but Turing's happen in
that note that the rate 2 Turing's
happened faster so we're okay but we're
using a curing rate which is constant at
its node so the total budget were using
is order of M but what it's not hard to
think of a dynamic policy that does with
very few curing resources start from the
left and start curing nodes one at a
time so I put a curing rate of two here
so this probability twice as much
probability that this will become cured
as opposed to this one becoming infected
so that boundary keeps moving at a
constant rate and we get quick curing
with a constant with a constant budget
do you need the constant budget now how
about more complicated graph if you have
a mesh if you have a configuration okay
if you were to do things statically you
could give let's say Turing rate of five
to its node then at each node Turing's
would happen to faster than infection so
that boundary would keep moving
that's a budget order of n but we can do
better
think about putting
all your curing resources on just on the
boundary on the red nodes and my curing
rate is bigger than the rate at which
infections happen locally so that this
would be pushing that boundary at a
certain rate okay but what if the
configuration is not that nice and there
are some holes so that is also part of
the boundary should I put curing
resources here not really
that's a waste let that node be infected
don't worry about it
think about sort of the real kind of
nice smooth boundary and try to keep it
smooth perhaps by first curing that node
get a smooth boundary and then try to
push that boundary that way and such a
strategy basically keeps a boundary that
has size roughly order square root and
if we have n nodes pushes it at the
constant rate and gets a curing that's
kind of fast and so square root n would
be the amount of resources for fast
extinction if you have a mesh graph yeah
I could just put all my resources here
yeah it's essentially the same and would
okay so square root n is the amount of
the budget that we need what's what does
that number come from well it's really
the cut width of the graph that we have
here just in case you don't know what
cut widths are suppose that you start
with all nodes infected crusade would be
to start curing the rates one at a time
and as you do that while you do it
your nature is fighting you in
proportion to the cuts that you are
facing so kind of the cut is the rate at
which nature is fighting you in at any
point if you were to deterministically
your one try to cure one at a time and
the worst fight will be at some point in
the middle of this process where you
find where the cut is big
okay suppose I want to cure the nodes
one at a time in a way that I do not
have to face a very large cut along the
way so I minimize over all Crusades the
maximum cut that I'm going to encounter
and that quantity is called the cut
width of the graph and the basic claim
is that this is the quantity that
determines how hard it is to do cure a
crusade so for the mesh the cut which is
of course square root n in general the
cut width is np-hard to calculate on the
other hand still as a concept a well
defined concept before a graph we can
approximate it it's something that we
can use so the theorem would go if the
budget is at least a constant factor a
little above the cut width then there's
a policy that achieves quick extinction
and the idea of that policy is to find
that optimal deterministic crusade and
have the stochastic system try to track
it now random stuff will happen things
will not happen exactly according to
plan but you can use the little extra
budget that you have to kill the
deviations from the plan and then
continue sticking to the plan okay that
policy is essentially optimal and
there's a kind of matching lower bound
at least for graphs that have if you
take a family of graph in which the cut
with grow in proportion with the number
of nodes still there bounded degree if
the budget the budget can still be
linear but by a smaller constant factor
and it's below the can't wait then any
policy that you might consider will have
an extinction time expected extinction
time that grows exponentially with the
side of with the size of the graph and
the idea of the proof is that if you're
when you start with everybody infected
your cut your cut is zero when you start
and with nobody in fact your cut is zero
because the cut width is whatever the
cut with
is you have at some point in the
evolution you will have to encounter
such a big cut and when you encounter it
the rate of infections is bigger than
the budget that you have so it's an
uphill fight fighting a drift that's
against you that crossing that barrier
has exponentially small probabilities
that kind of the rough idea although the
execution of this argument is infinitely
more complicated just encountering a
negative drift in one place is not
enough to say that it's a big barrier
one needs to argue that this barrier is
last for a fair amount of time so it's a
big battle that we are going to be
losing okay so this is just an example
of taking a standard textbook problem
from Network science and posing a closed
loop control version of it and trying to
make as much progress as one could for
that specific problem there's a fair
number of open questions that are left
for variations of it but let me talk
about what one could do next by sort of
taking this as an example or paradigm
okay just repeat look at your textbook
find all the list of models out there
and try to do something of that same
kind so in each one of these models one
can pose problems of this type now of
course all of these involve
exponentially large state spaces they're
intractable so in each case one needs to
hunt for the right formulation where you
can prove something that's both
non-trivial and still possible and
mildly interesting so that would be the
control theorists agenda then chapter
two in systems and control education at
least in my days would be that one then
looks into inference so for all these
models you can say now suppose that we
have partial observations of the state I
mean so far in my formulation I had
assumed that some controller looks and
sees who's infected
who is not and does something okay so
inference problems good literature out
there but plenty of room if you consider
all possible variations to ask other
questions so that's a popular topic in
inference you observe the trace and you
try to figure out who was the node that
started the epidemic okay who was the
preferred person that had the Zika virus
let's say or if we monitor it while it's
evolving the standard filtering problem
is to try to guess the states of those
nodes that you do not see if you want to
up the ante you're also active probing
so a flu epidemic may be happening in
some place you don't know you don't know
or maybe more serious epidemic should
you go and test random people and how
many and who and so on that gives a
class of problems that's quite
non-trivial and interesting okay and
then chapter three in systems and
control education is that you do both
inference and control which means
controlling and a partially observed
system so that takes us one exponential
level up in sort of difficulty so here
one has to be very careful on how to
choose formulations to get anything to
be interesting anything interesting to
say so that's pretty open-ended but now
let me switch hats so far up to here
I've made no pretensions about doing
anything useful or practical just
mathematician sees plenty fun with it
it's just the mathematicians exercise
recreational and that's fine now we want
to do want to transport ourselves to
other worlds what possible were
to do what's happening in the let's say
the narrative sciences take those models
build narratives about them do some
illustrations around them with math
formulas and make a story and so that's
one one direction of work but the
engineers do something useful realistic
sort of concrete questions for example
instead of modeling epidemics by looking
one note at the time probably you should
be looking one village at the time and
talking about the fraction of people who
are infected in that village should have
some relation with Rihanna so first
thing we should be before we played with
the model it with literature in this
field how much tries to do that okay so
we should fit models to data no boy told
me yesterday about the nice quotes that
I traced for moment said give me four
parameters and I can fit an elephant
give me five parameters and I can also
make it wiggles we do it strum and
actually you can fit an elephant with
four parameters models the fact that
your model fits the real data doesn't
mean it you may very well be overfitting
and that's kind of serious and of
business it's much more frustrating and
time-consuming than the proving theorems
and for most people it's not as much fun
that has to be done even the pistol
methodology itself has to be validated
that is if my methodology I'd use it in
some graph and they think that they saw
a power-law
I should test my methodology and data
generated from elsewhere that they're
not power loss and see if my method
always says I see a paradise a power
know probably the method is theirs and
finally even harder even the harder part
is that even if we have a model that
says at least he sounds fits the modern
property has been validated or not if we
want to apply it in a controlled setting
I think at all that your mother will
still be habitable so the model may be
very well capturing the truth of what
happens the way a system is operating
now but if you start operating it
differently maybe the damage will change
people will be
differently so if you see that your
neighbor is always shouting quote oh
maybe you just shoot your neighbor I
think independent it'll help out of the
network so the dynamics are not really
what you have been as well so there's
lots of very good and week's agenda here
one can see what can be done this
because a good work that has been
happening in those dimensions but I
think it's really touching only a small
fraction of what's possible so one thing
I was thinking I like your than having
more of one thing I was thinking about
those that sometimes cost time or
resource to move the turret around yeah
the model is really stylized it's a toy
model yeah I don't realize it but an
optimal bullet is actually to shoot all
your resource at one node at a time
there's no advantage in spreading your
resources in multiple notice for example
so that's an unrealistic part and let
you Father things I've got three sizes
of
try to get some insights but without
glazing always get across yeah
so my question is identical to Mike's
but I will rephrase it slightly so I can
ask a little bit has anyone else to
finish models that involve some friction
to move your resources around
dynamically or their other actual
network type problems no problems I
think what you found
there's been lots of work in the public
policy literature on an immunization
strategy like Larry wine at the Stanford
GSB I think but that's not it doesn't
model the micro network structure I
thought that point you made it was
interesting John about kind of the value
of modeling the network actually that
was the question I was gonna ask is
right there mean that there's a lot of
fluid models that are used for
immunization policy and those food
models I guess they have very complex
sort of differential equation
description of the macro dynamics of the
system they don't really model network
it would be that seems like a very
natural kind of validation test if the
value of network modeling like there if
you were to get down the level of
modeling network interactions would it
be the substantially different
conclusions about what the policy is
exactly that the macro level is right in
the fluid equations would be proper but
then you would have to kind of relive
regularity to be neighbourhoods or
villages actually try to do this us
States so there's the 50 states and flu
epidemics happening and then there's
people who travel and there's data about
interstate travel and try to figure out
how much interstate travel effects the
infection trans out of doing the real
work is simply difficult complicated the
practical one firstly a few epidemic
model is nothing like this plane
si es model the temperate temperature
and humidity is the main driver of the
epidemic and somehow you need to model
that effect learn it take it out and
then see there's an extra increment that
comes from travel so that last chapter
of we can see the questions there but
the data are not there they're not so
clean the true model is much more
complicated question
so thank you